[Music]
four turtles four brothers repetitive
narration named after the
Renaissance masters and free wait is
this the movie or a trailer an evil born
3,000 years ago oh good
evil born 3,000 years ago evil is always
better when it comes from the BC are the
colors gonna be like this during the
whole flashback because I will go ahead
and stab my eyeballs to save trouble I
see this movie went to the underworld
school of not giving a shit if you can
tell which guys are which every 3,000
years the stars with a long every 3,000
years something will align cliche
brotherhood was turned to stone man this
is a very knowledgeable portal to know
which people it needs to turn to stone
they became a more old approach this
movie's trying to set a record for the
most cliches in the first five minutes
the pong doubles over there 13 the
mobsters released Jesus should I be
taking notes
ok portal and we made the guy who opened
us immortal yes have we turned his best
friends into stone did that okay unleash
the 13 monsters and our job here is done
and the monsters that were unleashed
continued to plague mankind to this very
day if any city that was built in the
last 3,000 years doesn't look like the
old arcade game rampage I'm gonna ask
for my money back the animators said
let's draw this guy eating an apple
it'll make him look like even more of an
asshole
I tried ripping a girl's necklace off in
one clean break once the reason I did it
is none of your business
the point is that that necklace did not
break and I got kicked in the balls yeah
watch going asshole character must
always be an asshole or the kids in the
audience might forget he's a bad guy man
those steep drops and jungles just show
up out of nowhere all the time don't
they
this birds flying away cliche symbolizes
all the blood that the bad guy just
spilled to keep a PG rating Leonardo is
lucky this truck he sent in driverless
didn't hit a little kid or something how
many backpacks did she murder while
trying to master this trick April
O'Neil's job in this movie is oddly
specifically tailored to bring the plot
to the Turtles movie rips off the entire
gang is separated and all working
regular jobs thing from the Muppets Take
Manhattan also I sure hope we're not
gonna spend the whole movie waiting for
the four turtles to get back together
haha turtle and a half costume kid gag
with the trashcan but isn't your secret
parking spot completely busted the first
time a garbage man comes along and tries
to do his job twice
um cuz poop why do you do this yourself
Mikey those glory days are over but why
because winter sent one of the four of
you to Central America I suppose you
think the Nightwatch are some kind of
hero how do these assholes that live
with him not know that he's the night
watcher I don't think you can keep the
Giuliani justice like this a secret in
your own living quarters and there are
way too many clues you into everything
real estate technology pharmaceuticals
hair gel
I don't wear hair gel the screenwriters
didn't write dialogue either I was born
this highly secure museum allows cargo
to be carried through with showrooms
with easily tipped unsecured valuable
artifacts on display also April Lim
suitcase he is you let this asshole
carry crates through an area like this
and don't expect him to mess something
up TMNT steals mr. incredible from The
Incredibles this immortal asshole has
been searching for these statues for
3,000 years but April troops is off to
the Central American rainforest and
finds them instantly and it's time to
stumble upon Leonardo and catch up a bit
my associate Casey nice to meet you Ken
haha he's rich and forgets people's
names immediately after being told he
had come here to hurt you you'd be
honored you already
was there a need for stealth then
couldn't you just schedule a meeting and
not go through all the stress of
bringing ninjas to a negotiation I have
some friends coming to town that I'd
like to roll out the red carpet for
winters is unnecessarily vague about the
friends who are coming so it'll be a
surprise in the movie later you may have
everyone else fooled but you haven't
fooled me raft even this dumbass Casey
knows Raphael is the night watcher
I think Rafael's read too many
spider-man comics I can't even sleep
without the son of the subway rumblin
over my head
said no New Yorker ever Raphael is doing
what the one person who bought a ticket
of this movie was doing when he wants
the scene reviving three
thousand-year-old statues can be
accomplished with the use of a thing
Leo's a turtle sickle because until you
can act as one you have a villain to
fight this is a totally arbitrary plot
device and makes a little sense
Leonardo go to Central America by
yourself and become a leader
I'm sure the time alone will give you
amazing management skills meanwhile the
other three turtles will be forbidden to
fight while you're gone resenting you
becoming weak out of shape and out of
practice until you return
also again splinter demonstrates a
complete and total disregard for the
safety of all the people being robbed
killed beaten etc while he teaches his
pupils important mental lessons and the
night watcher was the only guy to pick
up the slack Raphael is basically
beating it into Leonardo's head that
he's the night watcher guy with his
attitude suddenly defends a total
stranger
on a full third of this movie goes by
before all four turtles are even in the
same place at the same time good thing
to hear along turtle hiatus has ended
exactly as the bad guys statue reviving
plan kicks into gear geez
all these ninjas turn and look after the
retreat hand signal
if the silent hand signal is that
unimportant why do it Foot Clan survives
jumping off this building because
assumptions
Donatello staff saves him because
cartoon physics thank god this is an
abandoned building under construction
instead of a real building in everyday
use because otherwise it would have to
feel conflicted about all this wanton
destruction movie shoplifts the setting
from the finale of Iron Monkey why did
the Foot Clan bother fighting with the
monster if they were just gonna tell
winters that it was here and he could
send his statue army after it also a
movie think smashing together the Iron
Man power source and the Hal 9000 will
create something original these statues
easily take care of the fuzzy monster
which was handily defeating all four
turtles at once but don't worry I'm sure
our heroes will find a way to overcome
this vastly superior opponent
Michelangelo was the first turtle to
jump into the sewers but climbs all the
way back up to say this inspirational
line we never see anything about these
monsters that's true this is why being
big about stuff like this is pretty
stupid and short-sighted we made a deal
karai and I expect you to almond but why
did you even need to make a deal with
the foot in the first place by the time
the furry monsters appeared you were to
walk in your statue warrior friends so
what do you need the foot patrolling for
you may be the eyes of the muscle this
is clearly not the instructions you gave
them earlier after you told them to be
the eyes and ears you said greet them
warmly and bring them to me all you had
to do was say if you see some monsters
tell me I'll take care of them the end
breaking news report concerning last
night's fight just happens to be coming
on as soon as splinter turns on the TV
it sounds like something out of science
fiction
splitter somehow immediately knows the
news report involves the Turtles this
same exact story would have been on the
news the next day without them because
the Foot Clan was fighting the monster
before they even got there and all the
science fiction stuff would have still
applied I am most disappointed in you
brothers weren't they all a part of the
same brood isn't this splitting hairs
he's older by like 30 seconds or
something right save the brute vigilante
junk for that night watchman
Knight Leonardo had no problem
remembering night watcher last night but
now suddenly can't remember the name the
next morning I didn't see the statue
army anywhere in this fight I am
confused as to who was supposed to be
doing what in this movie where did this
dude come from did he know that the
monster was on a train and jumped down
onto the speeding train when he came by
monsters continue to play humanity but
no humanity ever sees them hot female
artifact collector is also a kung-fu
expert because cartoon witnesses say the
news still doesn't know anything about
this story other than the holes in the
floors but this is still a science
fiction story that gets the Turtles in
trouble meanwhile newspapers don't give
a shit about that story and are still
covering night watcher like it's
brand-new we got bigger things to worry
about that night thing criminals like
what perfect timing is perfect
fortunately for the human Casey this
Chase takes place along a path where all
the gaps between buildings are jumpable
what's the monster hunting army just
hanging out in the alley waiting for the
bad monster to show up also how that has
no one's seen a monster like this flying
around New York City it's impossible and
I mentioned we ran into a monster last
night Flash King night
that whole montage with the statue dudes
capturing tons of monsters that was all
in one night guys who the boss man
specifically said with the muscles show
up long after any muscles required
basically they're the driver of the
paddy wagon the foot did all the work on
this capture he's just tackle the guy
and take cover if you've got the time to
know what's coming
before time was spent on the logistics
of this burp and the plot of this movie
looks South American that's your
department April how has she not seen
this already 3,000 years ago some great
warrior April just happens to know the
exact myth that actually happens to be
coming true right now also April's just
giving us the same story we got in the
opening flashback with some of the same
flashback he footage as well also a
movie unwittingly lays the groundwork
for Dragonball Evolution story structure
this has winters name written all over
it when selling poisoned darts do you
need to have your company name written
on it would it be better not to have
your name written on it fine then I quit
Jesus it's the only story we know how to
tell with these guys what is good curse
is broken
would no longer be even more when
winners became immortal and his brothers
turn to stone when the monster seemed to
be an entirely separate by-product but
now we're being told that the statute
curse is tied to the monster somehow
this portal must be the most random evil
to hit earth ever port of the ship to
open in the next 24 hours you at least
it's just enough time to stop it
and when the portal opens we'll lose the
city to monsters within hours within
days the country and within weeks the
world movie unintentionally writes the
entire treatment for Pacific Rim in a
throwaway line of dialogue like Halley's
Comet only monsters come on so wait this
portal opens every 3,000 years and
monsters come out every time after 4.5
billion years there should literally be
millions of monsters on earth and
virtually no humans know I do pick the
blue flower and climb to the top of the
mountain and not die while doing it
discount Batman also just go to 32nd
Street anywhere you'll find the
disturbance somehow this is the exact
same newspaper from several days ago
when Casey was reading it also is that
the only reason why there's a guy in
here who's oblivious to the kook
freaking out so they can have a joke
about him also being oblivious to the
night watcher walking right by and while
he reads about him this is a strangest
musical cue ever Black Betty an
african-american work song made popular
by Ram Jam in 1977 one of the 13
Monsters is basically Jack Jack I'll
never understand this kind of thing in
movies this guy was afraid of the little
gremlin that was in the kitchen a
vigilante comes in and disposes of the
gremlin and now the guy's afraid of the
vigilante for no reason at all other
than Raphael needs to learn a lesson
he decides to be spider-man for a bit
you can't change the world like this God
is there any reason why another
vigilante can't be fighting crime in
this city assuming that I want or isn't
Raphael how would he be hurting the
turtles in any way ah wait he didn't
know that was wrath are you being
serious Casey knew because the night
watcher look like a giant metal turtle
how did Leo miss that clue
don't do this rap I'm done taking orders
this entire movie is a brother's back
again how does a statue army know where
to be to shoot poison darts if it was
the Foot Clan giving them information
they know damn well that Leonardo isn't
the 13th monster and wouldn't even
bother reporting it to them not you MA
by a monster yo no different but why if
it's clear to the Stone Temple Pilots
that Leonardo is not a monster surely
the guy who's been living on earth for
three thousand years would notice also
when you resolve not to find the
thirteenth monster and go with this ruse
did you expect to find a Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle running around to take a
monster's place no law strong passionate
loyal to a fault these are the merits of
a great leader as well so maybe I should
send you to Central America for
all-important leadership training - Raph
let's win or go through all his pep talk
bullshit instead of just instantly
screaming Leo got captured Nando
splinter is gonna take a moment to
ponder that which allows you a moment to
ponder how much he looks like chester
Cheetah I'll tell you what we're gonna
do we're gonna rescue our brother and
then we're gonna save New York City well
okay then I don't need to watch it then
right sounds pretty straightforward I
got it on my last trip to Japan you like
it yes I do
oh wait she was talking to Casey wasn't
she also I stole it from Emma Thurman
who stole it from Bruce Lee no one who
watches the skies for a living notices
issue and then suddenly thousands of
foot soldiers previous TMNT material
aside April O'Neil is an artifact
collector she doesn't fight crime she's
shown no propensity for ass-kicking the
whole movie but now she's helping the
Turtles with her apparently
world-renowned ass-kicking these Foot
Clan guys they're just awful if they
ever want to fight against anything if
you can run on the shoulders of your
enemies why did you bother fighting any
of them in the first place sure was a
good thing Casey was clumsy earlier so
he could know about this Leo has been
unconscious since his capture but he
comes to just as he's rescued and is
even ready to fight just a few minutes
later that's what this is about mr.
O'Neil penance so why did you spend the
whole movie acting like a bad guy and
deliberately giving vague information
there's suddenly a good guy moment makes
no sense with one monster still free doc
curse will never be evil dude spell out
the plan for all the potential good guys
in attendance
turtles have to learn to be a team
before their big final showdown where
they all fight individually everyone in
New York City is like the nazgl they
don't notice all these monsters
conveniently come through the exact spot
where splinter can knock them back into
the pool so did we win I don't know dude
guess is as good as mine I gave up
trying to follow this plot ages ago
pesky missing final monster issue sorts
itself out quite nicely this is truly
the dumbest portal ever what is its
purpose it randomly drops monsters
everywhere for
what reason and then you can just send
monsters back if you have the power to
do so the portal needs to reassess its
life plan maybe go to Central America
and learn leadership your friends just
had a horrible crash though might want
to check on them
oh of course this didn't hurt anyone we
will have further business together the
kind day involves familiar faces from
your past just say shredders coming back
already and be done with it
Jesus the effects of the portal wait
until after winters tells everybody
thanks before taking him up to heaven or
whatever we live together we train
together we fight together hey remember
when Laurence Fishburne was narrating
this movie back in the beginning yeah me
too
good times
[Music]
it's impossible
dinette itself as my son goes through is
Jay VIX I know be Petra's MOV Stratos
[Music]
good you're swimming in the East River
the most heavily trafficked overly
contaminated water way on the eastern
seaboard
[Music]
[Applause]
we are getting aggravated
yes wheel